On nous le répète assez souvent, une bonne partie de ce que nous sommes est déterminée par nos gènes.
Ces gènes on les a hérités de nos parents à la fécondation et a priori, pas moyen d'en changer.
Et pourtant à la fin de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
aux Pays-Bas il s'est passé une chose étrange.
Pendant l'hiver 44-45
dans le nord-ouest du pays
il y a eu une famine, provoquée par un blocus allemand, et elle a fait environ 20000 morts chez les néerlandais
Mais outre les morts directs, cette famine a eu aussi des conséquences sur les descendants des survivants.
Soixante ans plus tard on a remarqué que les petits-enfants des femmes enceintes pendant la famine
étaient plus petits, plus gros et plus susceptibles de tomber malade que les autres enfants d'âge équivalent.
Les petits enfants hein ! C'est à dire que les effets de la famine ont persisté sur au moins deux générations après l'événement.
Comment on peut expliquer ça ? C'est comme si la famine avait altéré les gènes des survivants et s'était transmise à leurs descendants ?
Aujourd'hui on pense qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un phénomène génétique mais épigénétique.
Et on va voir que la différence est importante.
Pour comprendre ce qu'est l'épigénétique, il va falloir aller à l'intérieur de nos cellules.
Et pour ça j'ai demandé un coup de main à P'tite Jane qui anime l'excellente émission "In Cellulo".
Alors P'tite Jane, tu nous présentes ta chaîne ?
Salut David ! Chez moi on parle de biologie cellulaire
histoire de comprendre comment tout ce petit monde de notre corps fonctionne.
Bon je parle aussi d'autres choses mais pour aujourd'hui promis je surveille mon langage et on reste sur la bio.
Maintenant que les présentations sont faites, plongeons au cœur de nos cellules.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Commençons par les bases, comme vous le savez sans doute, dans nos cellules le support chimique de nos gènes c'est l'ADN.
l'ADN c'est une longue séquence constituée de quatre bases nucléotides : adénine, guanine, cytosine et thymine
qui sont reliées entre elles
par la structure en sucre désoxyribose.
Cette séquence code pour tous nos différents gènes, comme un plan de montage de toutes nos protéines.
Bien à l'abri dans nos noyaux on retrouve deux brins d'ADN complémentaires, comme deux copies de sauvegarde.
L'adénine s'assemble alors avec la thymine et la guanine avec la cytosine formant les barreaux de la fameuse structure en double hélice de l'ADN.
Le long de la séquence, un gène code pour une protéine
et un gros complexe protéique appelé l'ARN polymérase,
va permettre de lire l'ADN et d'assembler l'ARN correspondant.
C'est l'étape de transcription.
L'ARN, un seul brin court avec une structure en ribose, est suffisamment petit pour sortir du noyau de la cellule.
Il sert alors de messager entre le plan de montage, dans le noyau, et le cytoplasme où se trouvent les usines à protéines, les ribosomes.
Ces ribosomes décodent la séquence de l'ARN et assemblent les protéines pendant l'étape de traduction.
Les protéines, ainsi produites à partir de nos gènes, sont un peu comme les ouvrières de nos cellules.
Elles ont tout un tas de rôles différents pour permettre à notre organisme de bien fonctionner.
Un point clé c'est que
quand une de nos cellules se divise
l'ADN qu'elle contient est répliqué à l'identique et donc toutes les cellules de notre corps contiennent le même ADN.
Alors bien sûr il peut y avoir des mutations génétiques des variations des bases A, T, G ou C.
Mais celles-ci interviennent de façon ponctuelle et aléatoire d'une cellule à l'autre.
Et à part ça c'est donc essentiellement le même ADN qu'on retrouve dans toutes nos cellules.
Et à première vue ça peut paraître bizarre...
Par exemple un neurone fonctionne de manière extrêmement différente d'une cellule du foie ou de la peau.
Si toutes les cellules
ont le même ADN,
elles devraient fabriquer les mêmes protéines et donc fonctionner de façon équivalente non ?
Et bien non car ce qui fait la différence c'est que chaque cellule n'exploite pas l'ensemble des gènes contenus dans son ADN.
Selon la fonction de la cellule, l'endroit où elle se trouve dans notre organisme
notre âge ou le fait que nous soyons en train de dormir ou de digérer,
les gènes utilisés par chacune de nos cellules vont varier.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'expression des gènes.
Chaque type de cellules exprime, utilise,
des gènes qui lui sont spécifiques même si certains gènes sont utilisés dans presque toutes les cellules.
Ce qui permet à une cellule d'exprimer les gènes dont elle a besoin
ce sont souvent ce qu'on appelle des facteurs de transcription.
Il s'agit de protéines qui permettent de stimuler, ou au contraire d'inhiber,
la transcription d'un gène en ARN et donc la production des protéines associées à ce gène.
Et finalement ce qui va faire la différence entre par exemple un neurone et une cellule du foie
ça n'est pas des variations dans leur ADN mais dans la manière dont celui-ci va être lu et utilisé.
Et pourtant dans les années 70 on a découvert que les cellules vivantes utilisaient d'autres mécanismes pour changer l'expression des gènes.
Des mécanismes
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui épigénétiques
car ils sont capables de modifier la molécule d'ADN elle-même sans pour autant toucher à la séquence des bases A, G, T et C.
L'exemple le plus connu c'est la méthylation de l'ADN.
Le méthyle c'est un petit morceau de molécule qui peut venir s'accrocher entre autres au niveau des bases C de l'ADN.
Quand des groupes méthyle viennent se fixer ainsi, ils gênent le processus de transcription de l'ADN en ARN
et diminuent donc la production des protéines associées aux gênes où ils sont accrochés.
Cela peut avoir pour effet de complètement éteindre le gène concerné.
Comme si on avait mis
du scotch sur le plan de montage.
Il existe d'autres marqueurs épigénétiques, non pas sur la molécule d'ADN en elle même, mais sur les protéines qui la structurent.
Pour faire entrer une séquence de 3 mètres de long dans un noyau d'à peine 1 centième de millimètre de large
l'ADN doit être extrêmement condensé.
Pour ça l'ADN s'enroule autour d'un groupe de 8 protéines, appelées des histones
et forme une structure en collier
de perles plus ou moins resserré.
Certains facteurs de transcription peuvent contrôler cette condensation.
Ils ajoutent ou enlèvent un groupement méthyle ou un groupement acétyle, un autre petit morceau de molécules
directement sur les histones.
La combinaison de tous ces groupes sur l'ADN et sur les histones contrôle l'état de compaction du collier de perles
qui joue un rôle important dans l'expression des gènes.
Lorsque l'ADN est trop condensé, le complexe de transcription ne peut plus accéder à la séquence de l'ADN pour la lire
tout simplement
pour des raisons spatiales.
Ces modifications peuvent être transitoires, permettant à la cellule de réguler finement certains gènes en temps réel pour pouvoir s'adapter à son environnement.
Mais dans d'autres cas ces marqueurs épigénétiques peuvent être plus permanents.
Par exemple chez les individus porteurs de deux chromosomes X
classiquement de sexe féminin
les gènes portés par ses chromosomes pourraient s'exprimer deux fois plus que chez les individus XY ce qui pourrait poser des problèmes.
Pour éviter ça l'un des deux chromosomes X est compacté de façon stable, via notamment une méthylation importante de l'ADN et des histones.
Cette inactivation au hasard d'un des chromosomes X a lieu très tôt dans le développement embryonnaire
mais elle est maintenue dans les cellules tout au long de leurs divisions successives.
D'ailleurs c'est pour ça que seules
les chattes peuvent porter 3 couleurs.
Les couleurs noire et rousse étant deux versions d'un même gène porté sur le chromosome X.
Les taches sur le pelage marquent alors les zones de cellules dans lesquelles l'un ou l'autre des chromosomes a été inactivé.
Vous voyez donc qu'en plus de nos gènes il existe un certain nombre de marques épigénétiques
susceptibles d'influencer leurs expressions.
Et ces variations ne sont pas rares.
Prenez des jumeaux homozygotes, ce qu'on appelle des vrais jumeaux
ils sont issus de la même cellule œuf et ont donc le même ADN.
Mais leurs marqueurs épigénétiques peuvent être assez différents.
Une étude publiée en 2005  a montré que les différences épigénétiques entre vrais jumeaux augmentaient avec l'âge,
qu'il s'agisse de la méthylation de l'ADN ou de l'acétylation des histones.
Si des jumeaux de 3 ans sont quasi identiques de ce point de vue
des jumeaux de 50 ans peuvent avoir des niveaux de marqueurs épigénétiques très différents.
Et ce d'autant plus que les deux jumeaux ont eu une histoire et un mode de vie différent.
Et bien sûr si on parle de ces marques épigénétiques c'est que comme les variations génétiques classiques,
elles peuvent avoir des vraies conséquences sur les organismes et leur développement.
Il existe par exemple une fleur appelée "Linaria Vulgaris", la linaire commune, qui existe en deux variantes de forme.
La forme classique possède une symétrie axiale
tandis qu'une forme moins courante a une symétrie radiale.
La forme que va adopter la fleur est contrôlée par un gène.
Mais ce gène est strictement identique dans les deux cas.
Ce qui fait la différence c'est que dans la forme à symétrie radiale, il est fortement méthylé et donc il est inactivé.
Ce qui différencie ces deux variantes de la fleur
ça n'est donc pas une mutation classique du gène c'est la présence des groupes méthyle.
On parle parfois d'épimutation.
Chez les animaux aussi les conséquences
peuvent être importantes.
Dans le modèle de souris Avy (NDT Agouti viable yellow), la couleur du pelage change en fonction de la méthylation du gène Agouti
passant du jaune en absence de méthylation
au noir ou pseudo Agouti lorsque l'ADN est très méthylé.
De plus alors que les souris pseudo Agouti maintiennent un poids normal tout au long de leur vie
les souris jaunes ou tachetées deviennent obèses en vieillissant.
Ceci est donc contrôlé, non pas par le gène Agouti lui-même, mais par son état de méthylation.
Encore plus fort, en 2006 une équipe de chercheurs a nourri des souris Avy gestantes avec un régime riche ou non en génistéine
une molécule qu'on retrouve dans le soja par exemple.
Les souris nourries avec le régime riche ont eu plus de petits pseudo Agouti.
Ces souriceaux présentent une hyper méthylation du gène maintenu tout au long de leur vie
et un risque plus faible d'obésité à l'âge adulte.
Le régime alimentaire in utero peut donc affecter durablement l'expression de certains gènes en modifiant de façon permanente l'épigénome.
Et ceci peut avoir des conséquences importantes sur l'état santé tout au long de la vie.
Mais évidemment pour que ces effets demeurent à l'échelle d'un organisme entier, il faut que la méthylation persiste lors des divisions cellulaires
et donc se maintienne pendant la réplication de l'ADN.
Et justement pour cela
il existe une enzyme spécifique
DNMT1
qui se charge lors de la réplication de l'ADN de méthyler le nouveau brin.
Et donc les méthylations sont conservées comme le seraient les mutations génétiques classiques.
Et pourtant une différence importante entre les épimutations et les mutations classiques
c'est que les épimutations sont facilement réversibles.
Ce sont juste des marques sur l'ADN et elles peuvent donc facilement être ajoutées ou enlevées.
Un autre aspect essentiel des épimutations et qui peut paraître surprenant au premier abord
c'est qu'elles peuvent s'hériter,
être transmises à la descendance.
Un bel exemple c'est celui des fleurs dont je vous ai parlé, les linaires communes.
Si une fleur a subi une méthylation qui fait qu'elle adopte une forme radiale, ça sera le cas aussi de ses descendantes.
En se reproduisant la plante ne transmet pas seulement ses gènes mais aussi les marques épigénétiques portées par son ADN.
Et l'état méthylé du gène peut se maintenir ainsi de génération en génération.
Mais ça reste réversible. Si aux premiers stades de croissance pour une raison ou une autre
la plante perd la méthylation de ce gène et bien elle se développera avec une symétrie axiale.
Chez les animaux ce n'est pas aussi simple.
La méthylation de l'ADN est effacée entre deux générations, non pas une fois mais deux.
L'ADN est ainsi entièrement déméthylé pendant la formation des gamètes, ovules et spermatozoïdes
et une seconde fois lors des premières étapes du développement embryonnaire.
Pourtant il existe bien des exemples
de transmission d'épimutations.
Les mécanismes ne sont pas encore très clairs mais ça pourrait passer par le maintien des marquages épigénétiques des histones
par des processus impliquant des petits ARN régulateurs
ou encore par d'autres marquages épigénétiques encore inconnus.
Ainsi le statut de méthylation du gène Agouti et ses conséquences physiologiques se transmettent sur deux générations avant d'être perdus.
De la même façon, l'exposition de souris gestantes par des perturbateurs endocriniens
perturbe la fertilité masculine de la descendance pendant au moins 4 générations.
Ces perturbations sont encore une fois non pas liées à des modifications de l'ADN
mais à des altérations du profil de méthylation de celui-ci.
Mais des épimutations pourraient-elles être maintenues de façon plus stable que seulement quelques générations ?
Pour répondre à cette question des chercheurs ont mis au point des mouches dans lequel le gène responsable
de la couleur rouge des yeux est plus ou moins exprimé selon des marquages épigénétiques.
En croisant plusieurs générations de mouches sélectionnées selon la couleur de leurs yeux, rouges ou blancs
on peut obtenir des épi-lignées stables, même après l'arrêt de la sélection.
Bien que les séquences ADN de ces mouches soient parfaitement identiques
elles transmettent le caractère couleur des yeux à leur descendance pendant des générations
via le maintien d'un marqueur épigénétique.
Au début de l'épisode je vous ai parlé de la famine néerlandaise de l'hiver 44-45
en vous racontant que tout semblait se passer comme si les conséquences de cette famine avait été héritées par les générations suivantes.
Est-ce qu'il pourrait donc s'agir d'un mécanisme épigénétique ?
Et bien c'est ce qu'on suppose. En particulier, des chercheurs ont pu montrer des différences de méthylation du gène IGF2
qui est associé à une hormone qui joue le rôle de facteur de croissance.
Chez les enfants ayant été exposés à la famine quand ils étaient encore dans l'utérus de leur mère
le gène IGF2 est moins méthylé que chez les individus du même âge qui n'ont pas connu la famine.
Et il existe d'autres études analogues à celle de la famine néerlandaise et qui suggèrent l'héritabilité des marques épigénétiques.
Par exemple l'étude dite d'Överkalix.
Alors Överkalix c'est un petit village paumé dans le nord de la suède
mais qui a une particularité très intéressante pour les chercheurs.
On y possède des registres très bien tenus de l'abondance des récoltes depuis des décennies
en plus des classiques registres d'état civil.
Et on a ainsi pu montrer qu'à Överkalix les hommes dont le grand-père a connu une période de disette, de faibles récoltes entre 9 et 12 ans
ont un taux de mortalité deux fois plus faible que ceux dont le grand-père a connu l'abondance au même âge
Cette période de la croissance, 9 à 12 ans, étant très importante
on pense que l'alimentation a pu influencer de façon déterminante les marques épigénétiques des habitants d'Överkalix
et que ça a pu donc être transmis à leur descendance et avoir des conséquences sur leur santé.
D'autres stress sont soupçonnés d'être responsables de conséquences sur la descendance via des altérations de l'épigénome.
Ainsi une étude sur 10 000 naissances a montré que des pères ayant fumé avant l'âge de 11 ans avaient plus de risques d'avoir des fils en surpoids.
Toutefois il faut rester très prudent lors de l'interprétation d'études sur des humains.
Y a-t-il d'autres facteurs, génétiques ou socioculturels par exemple
qui pourraient expliquer la différence entre les enfants issus de pères très jeunes fumeurs et les autres ?
Pour éviter ces biais on doit s'assurer que le nombre de cas de chaque groupe est suffisamment grand
et ajuster les différences observées selon toutes les autres caractéristiques de ces groupes.
À peu près tout l'inverse de ce qui a été fait dans une étude de 2015
qui étudiait les perturbations de l'épigénome chez les survivants de l'holocauste et leurs enfants.
Avec des groupes survivants de l'holocauste et descendances très limités, 32 et 22 respectivement,
et des groupes contrôles mal définis et ridiculement petits, 8 et 9 personnes juives sans plus de précisions.
Cette étude a même été désignée étude épigénétique surinterprétée de la semaine à sa sortie.
Il est donc difficile pour l'humain de séparer les effets génétiques, épigénétiques ou simplement liés à l'environnement.
Souvent pour étudier ça, on utilise des populations de vrais jumeaux ayant été séparés à la naissance,
ayant grandi loin l'un de l'autre.
ADN identique mais marqueurs épigénétiques potentiellement différents.
Mais même ainsi ça reste difficile de distinguer correctement ce qui relève de l'épigénétique ou de l'environnement familial et culturel au sens large.
Et puis il y a une chose étonnante et perturbante avec ces histoires épigénétiques
c'est qu'elles ont un petit goût de néo-Lamarckisme.
Néo-Lamarckisme ?
Revenons un peu sur la théorie de l'évolution.
On pense parfois à tort que l'idée d'évolution a été introduite par Darwin.
Mais ça n'est pas le cas.
Ce que Darwin a proposé de nouveau c'est le mécanisme de cette évolution, la sélection naturelle.
Avant Darwin d'autres avaient déjà proposé que les espèces puissent évoluer
et par exemple le naturaliste français Jean Baptiste de Lamarck avait d'abord suggéré un mécanisme différent.
Selon lui les espèces pouvaient acquérir de nouveaux caractères, s'adapter
en fonction de leurs besoins et de leur environnement.
L'exemple de Lamarck qu'on cite souvent est celui de la girafe.
D'après la théorie de Lamarck, la raison pour laquelle les girafes auraient un long cou
c'est qu'en étant dans un environnement avec de la nourriture en hauteur
et bien cette pression aurait poussé chaque girafe à s'adapter
en développant un cou un peu plus long que les précédentes.
Et cette variation se produisant au cours de sa vie, elle pouvait ensuite la transmettre à sa descendance.
C'est une idée de Lamarck qu'on appelle l'hérédité des caractères acquis.
Mais vous le savez, ensuite, Darwin a remplacé cette idée par celle de sélection naturelle.
Ce que dit Darwin c'est que ça n'est pas que la girafe développe un cou plus long sous la pression de son environnement
mais plutôt qu'un jour du fait du hasard et bien une girafe va naître avec un cou un peu plus long.
Ça lui donnera peut-être un avantage par rapport aux autres et donc plus de chances de survivre et de se reproduire.
Bref au niveau des mécanismes de l'évolution le Lamarckisme, l'hérédité des caractères acquis, a été supplanté par le Darwinisme, la sélection naturelle.
Mais si vous avez bien suivi, vous avez peut-être noté que l'épigénétique semble se comporter comme le Lamarckisme.
Votre histoire personnelle, votre environnement, votre alimentation, votre comportement
peuvent avoir une influence sur votre état épigénétique.
Et ce dernier peut même être en partie transmis à votre descendance.
Alors du coup est-ce que des caractères acquis pourraient devenir héréditaires ? C'est à dire est ce que Lamarck avait aussi un peu raison ?
Et bien sur le papier oui et pour autant il faut rester modéré
car l'épigénétique ne va pas non plus fondamentalement remettre en question les principes de sélection naturelle.
On sait que les effets épigénétiques restent réversibles, qu'ils sont assez faibles et que chez les animaux
on peut aujourd'hui difficilement prouver qu'ils persistent au delà de quelques générations.
En revanche s'il y a bien un domaine sur lequel l'épigénétique pourrait permettre de nombreux progrès
et pourquoi pas même à l'avenir soigner des patients : la recherche contre le cancer.
Comme expliqué dans la très complète vidéo de David sur le sujet
le cancer est une multiplication incontrôlée des cellules de notre propre corps
liée des altérations au niveau cellulaire.
Classiquement on pensait que ces altérations étaient surtout des mutations de l'ADN
et c'est sur ces mutations et sur les processus cellulaires qu'elles affectent qu'on base les thérapies.
Mais depuis quelques années on se rend compte de l'importance de l'épigénome dans ce processus
que ce soit par des aberrations au niveau de la méthylation de l'ADN
ou des modifications des histones ou encore de petits ARN non codants régulant la stabilité d'autres ARN.
Et mieux comprendre ces perturbations de l'épigénome pourrait pourquoi pas à l'avenir nous permettre de développer des nouvelles stratégies thérapeutiques.
Comme vous le voyez sans être à ce jour une révolution complète de la biologie
l'épigénétique montre des mécanismes nouveaux qui influencent nos organismes
au-delà des effets génétiques classiques.
Et pourtant gardez un esprit critique car il semblerait que l'épigénétique soit très à la mode
chez les naturopathes, les thérapeutes quantiques et toutes les médecines alternatives de tout poil.
Alors non,
l'épigénétique ne va pas vous permettre de rebooter votre génome en buvant du jus de citron ou la graine de yack.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo. Un grand merci à P'tite Jane pour sa contribution
et surtout n'oubliez pas d'aller voir sa chaîne et vous y abonner, je vous la recommande vraiment.
Je vous mettrai tous les liens qu'il faut en description.
À bientôt !